[Música]
y es momento de hablar de economía en
france 24 y para eso me acompaña jorge
hurtado en el estudio jorge buenas
noches buenas noches angela vamos a
comenzar hablando de la crisis
energética en europa tema ampliamente
abordado de nuestras noticias de hoy y
bueno y es que la noticia del día no la
comisión la presidenta la comisión
europea- ursula von der leyen propuso
que los países de la unión europea
deberían fijar un tope de precios para
el gas natural ruso russia ya cortado
parcial o totalmente el suministro de
gas a 13 países de la unión europea que
utilizan el combustible para calentar
los hogares generar electricidad y hacer
funcionar las fábricas el gas de los
gasoductos rusos representaba el 40 por
ciento de todo el gas importado en
europa antes de la guerra pero ahora
sólo representa el 9 por ciento el
presidente ruso vladimir putin por su
parte amenazó con cortar por completo el
suministro de energía a occidente si
éste intenta limitar esos precios o
poner que pase la propuesta como tal
según el rusia tiene suficientes
clientes en asia para reemplazar las
exportaciones de europa pero según la
comisión europea las reservas ya están
al 82%
la capacidad esperada para la llegada
del invierno a mediados de diciembre de
este año el kremlin culpa a occidente de
la suspensión de los suministros por las
acciones occidentales contra gazprom
alegando que éstas obstaculizan el
mantenimiento normal de los equipos de
los gasoductos y es por eso estos cortes
repetidos y continuará el capítulo vamos
a pasar a américa latina' la inflación
no da tregua en ecuador ese país
registró en agosto el precio más alto de
la canasta básica familiar en toda su
historia el costo de la canasta básica
pasó de 753 a 754 dólares un aumento del
0.07 por ciento entre julio y agosto de
este año el aumento anual ha sido un
poco mayor de 41,15 dólares el mayor
gasto de los ecuatorianos dentro de la
canasta familiar está en miscelánea
seguido de alimentos y bebidas vivienda
e indumentaria pero de todos los
productos el que más ha subido el precio
es la salud
jorge se espera además que la inflación
anual en argentina alcance 99 6% para
fin de año bueno incluso que se mantenga
por arriba del 100 por ciento en el
primer semestre del próximo año según la
consultora ecog los temores de recesión
global los altos precios de la energía y
la devaluación de la moneda local
propician un escenario bastante negativo
para los próximos meses hay en argentina
el nuevo ministro de economía sergio
massa se encuentra en eeuu en reuniones
con el fondo monetario internacional
esto para asegurar el cumplimiento del
acuerdo de deuda por 44 mil millones de
dólares que tiene con ese organismo hoy
se conoció también que el banco mundial
va a entregar en los próximos seis meses
un préstamo de 900 millones de dólares a
argentina para que intente sobrellevar
esta crisis económica una noticia que
les interesa los seguidores de la
manzana apple presentó el iphone 14 así
es la compañía presentó el iphone 14
unos nuevos auriculares air pot pro y
una actualización de la paul white que
incluye el primer modelo ultra de la
historia el iphone conserva este iphone
14 conserva el aspecto general de la
versión anterior pero mejoras en la
cámara así como una nueva función de
mensajería por satélite es importante
destacar que apple no subió sus precios
en eeuu y esto pese a la inflación más
alta que enfrenta ese país en cuatro
décadas pero angela no sé si te has
preguntado cuántos salarios mínimos se
necesitan en américa latina' para
comprar esta última versión del iphone
14 pro que ronda los 1000 dólares y aquí
algunos datos que se dan en todos los
países de nuestra región adquirir este
teléfono requiere más de un mes de
salario un análisis de bloomberg en
línea reveló que en costa rica por
ejemplo un trabajador podría comprarlo
en dos meses y dedica el cien por ciento
de su salario a ello en el salvador
brasil un trabajador debería dedicar
cuatro meses de salario para adquirirlo
en colombia' cinco meses de trabajo pero
el dato es más desigual en venezuela
donde se requiere al menos 33 salarios
mínimos para comprar el smartphone más
pocos meses en el mejor de los casos si
uno tiene un buen salario y le cuento yo
por eso no tengo vamos a hablar ahora de
la cifra del día por favor el 56,9
puntos eso registró en agosto el sector
de servicios de eeuu los economistas
esperaban que este valor cayera ya que
un dato superior a 50 indica crecimiento
económico y precisamente eso es lo que
no busca la reserva federal con la
subida de los tipos de interés esto es
resultado de un giro en los patrones de
gasto y el aumento salarial sostenido al
margen de la inflación y la subida de
los tipos que mencionábamos que ha hecho
la fed para tratar de controlar esa
inflación porque el agradecimiento para
usted y le deseo feliz noche ya nos
vamos a ver con el debate
[Música]